[Music]
at long now one of the things we say is
that we're striving to be good ancestors
it's it's part of the long view that
what we want to do for future
generations for people that are kids now
for their kids and on is to give them
more options more possibilities that's
one of the things that we're doing and
in all sorts of ways if you're at a fork
in the road which one gives more choices
to the future to the future inhabitants
and we don't talk about it a lot this
way but this networked
information technology world that we're
living in now is an amazing
intergenerational project and so the
backbones the protocols programming
languages these are infrastructure and
building blocks of what we're making
today and what will be made tomorrow and
that goes across the hardware the
software the concepts the UI concepts
the content the data all of those things
and if you are working on technology
today as as much as there may be
pressure to work on it for the
short-term reasons and business goals
that are in front of you you also need
to think that this these are precedents
that are being said tools that will be
available to then be extended into the
future and so our speaker tonight brian
behlendorf is in a really interesting
way his own ancestor
it it's not often that I can honestly
say that probably everyone in this room
has if you've been on the web today you
have run code that Brian had an
ancestral hand in with the the Apache
web server and with not only the
software but the organizations that have
come out both the Apache foundation the
open source initiative Mozilla
Foundation and the FF which he continues
to sit on the boards of he is we're
getting to speak to an architect who's
also swung a hammer on the job and we
are all benefiting and he is benefitting
as he's continuing in this layered way
that we do with technologies to build on
top of the Foundation's literally and
figuratively that have come before so I
think as we go into this talk tonight
there's a lot of hype around as there
always is around technology buzzwords
but I think the right way to approach
tonight's conversation is with a bit of
awe and a bit of gravity that we've
already built amazing things it was 30
years ago that Tim berners-lee had the
idea in 1988 that would then be
published as the first technology and
documentation in 89 for the web and
that's when that starts so what's being
done tonight and what's going to be
released next year what we've done so
far is awe-inspiring and it should only
increase our ambition for what we can do
into the future and with that let's ask
those questions to someone who ought to
know mr. brian behlendorf
cool well it's really an honor to speak
here if there are some fellow good
ancestors in the room so I appreciate
them coming out to listen to this and my
wife's here as well who's also given me
a reason to be a good ancestor because
we have a three-year-old daughter and
that's just it really does sharpen your
focus on thinking about the long term
and trying to you know do the Burning
Man thing if we leave it cleaner than
you found it right not just Leave No
Trace but yeah and a lot of that is
motivated kind of my thinking around why
I'm in involved in this space in the
first place I think I like many of you
you probably first heard about Bitcoin
around the time that it first appeared
on the the kind of dock in 2008 was when
satoshis first paper came out and I
think like many of you at that point I
was a little concerned that this
internet thing that we had built on top
of was resent realizing in a way I mean
it was never really totally
decentralized and we can have an
interesting conversation during the QA
about the word decentralization but it
was certainly a place that felt
flattered right it was a place where you
could run your own mail server you could
run your own website you could run a lot
of your own software you didn't have to
but the fact that you could was an
incredibly liberating kind of thing
right and there was just enough
decentralization on the Internet
that it was spawned it was I was a place
where a lot of new businesses could be
formed and I don't know if this makes me
a good ancestor or not but I along with
some others here were complicit in
putting the first ad banner on the web
and I've tell people I've been atoning
for it ever since
but but even in those days it felt like
the Internet was this wide open frontier
that by 2008 it didn't quite feel so
much as like a frontier it felt a little
more like things were organizing to get
back to perhaps what Thomas J Watson he
was the founder of IBM said which was
maybe there's only a market for actually
five of these computers in the world
right it turned out that they would be
you know Mike Microsoft Amazon Apple etc
and so at that point the the the launch
of Bitcoin kind of felt like like there
were a number of other projects along
these lines that were about
a set of developers going well can we
just reinvent the underlying protocols
to not have this you know centralizing
network effect right is there a way that
we can make it cheap again - and and
create a financial incentive and a
protocol that made it so that you could
host things in a decentralized way and
didn't have to worry about these centers
of gravity forming out there in the
world you put impossibly idealistic I
resonated with it but I had some issues
with it - I had some issues with the
idea of proof-of-work
serving as the fundamental basis for how
this works and and I can go and tune in
a bit but proof-of-work is basically
burning CPU power to run a lottery to
figure out who puts the next link in a
chain which for a lot of people as they
start looking at this makes you go I'm
not so sure I want to get into this I
kind of call it the mercury mining of
our generation right and that it's cool
technically but also kind of icky once
you get into it and certainly can leave
a toxic legacy what I also was concerned
about was whether a speculative
financial instrument really was the
right way to build the web 3-dot
was there a risk that this would be
gamed the way that financial markets
have always been gamed and we would find
a whole new set of empires being built
out of thin air fairly or unfairly right
because the internet never felt that way
Internet technologies and protocols you
released a piece of software the
thousandth person to adopt it didn't
benefit from it less than the first
person to adopt it right in fact they
probably benefited more it was a
snowball effect that grew and grew and
so I stayed kind of away from from
Bitcoin much to again our family's
detriment I did not invest early on in
Bitcoin or the others but kept my eye on
it and it was when I kind of realized
that there was perhaps another take on
it which was to look at the technology
underneath cryptocurrencies to try to
understand was there something
innovative and unique there and a way to
detach it from some of these things that
felt weird that I decided to jump in and
I'm not gonna make the these 30 minutes
that I'm gonna try to talk and can I try
to keep it limited to a pitch for what I
do but just by way of biography so I am
an executive director of something
called hyper ledger which is a
blockchain technology project hosted by
the Linux Foundation the Linux
Foundation has been
for about 15 years now trying to build
open-source communities in all sorts of
different spaces long beyond just the
Linux operating system where it started
now in in cloud computing Software
Defined Networking lots of things that
feel like plumbing but things that start
to get into the real world so we just
launched an energy related project for
example for software that runs the grid
a lot more to say about that it's kind
of more of a a kind of business
consortium kind of model but it provides
the resources to fund a program office
that act is kind of like an air traffic
control Network for contributors who
show up and want to build open source
code and so at hyper ledger we're the
home for hundreds of developers working
for hundreds of different companies
working together uncommon infrastructure
for blockchain technologies some of
which I'll hint at in the presentation
and if you're interested hyper ledger
org lots more to talk about there but I
really I really would just wanted to
leave you with today was perhaps a
different way of looking at what this
blockchain revolution means what this
technology means a different conceptual
frame and then actually this is nicely
paired with Wan Bennett's thing on
Monday because one I think is in some
ways in some ways I've been accused of
making blockchain boring because I try
to demystify it a bit and make it less
kind of magic pixie dust and hopefully
you'll appreciate that one does that -
he writes software ipfs is an amazing
series of different technologies and he
is truly thinking about the 20-year kind
of horizon and how do we reboot a lot of
fundamental fundamental architectures of
how the internet works I agree with
about 2/3 of it and 1/3 seems a little
wacky but I think that's right I think
they think you want that kind of balance
so I really encourage you to go see his
talk on Monday so to dive right in
and this is where Otto's picture came
from but I hopefully this helps frame it
for you if there was one one picture
that I could leave you with here about
what what blockchain technology is at
least the way that I define it the way a
lot of people I know who I know define
it is is that there's two underlying
innovations both of which seem fairly
banal when considered kind of by
themselves but I think in combination
really build something cool so the first
is a new approach to databases called a
distributed ledger and we've had
databases since the
of computing right databases are nothing
magical and we've actually gotten really
good at building big centralized
databases things that scale to the order
of hundreds of millions of transactions
a second reads you know infinite numbers
of reads right like things that the
scale of a Twitter or a Facebook with
all sorts of dials for consistency for
for you know liveness for all these
kinds of technical issues but we've
gotten good at that well we have not
gotten really good at until we've
returned to some of these technologies
is a decentralized database and a
decentralized database is one that we're
where the the what's what's in the
database and what's kept consistent is
not governed or limited or processed by
a central actor but is instead shared
amongst a network of potentially
mutually distrusting parties right and
so I the graphic here that otto drew was
really my attempt and and the the Swiss
artists attempt a processing mind my
attempt to show the distinction between
these two kinds of I don't even want to
call them networks because it's above
the layer of the network right on the
right sorry does anyone here work for
uber I don't want to like make you feel
like uncomfortable or anything like that
and and so I'm sorry but frankly if one
were to draw the architecture of uber
and its connections to its user base
right it would be the the drawing on the
left right uber runs a set of servers
that handle requests from mobile apps
from their web frontend etc and puts
them at the center of that universe and
they do a pretty good job I don't wanna
get into controversies about uber this
or that or whatever but in terms of
delivering a service that people can use
they you know centralization actually
works but it does put them in the pot in
the driver's seat literally no pun
intended of defining like how how the
system works how it evolves and also
what is the state of accounts between
with drivers with passengers if it turns
out somebody needs to be refunded they
can do that immediately that's fine but
they could all you know there is also
the risk that they could play God right
that they can change balances that they
could
you know run things in a way that if the
consumers noticed it great you know and
they'd be able to call them on it but
and that might be something that we
tolerate for a ride-sharing up but we
might not tolerate if we're talking
about a network of banks wanting to send
money to each other having somebody at
the center that can play God presents a
level of risk that's hard to quantify
but is very real and so for a lot of
reasons we want to build networks an
application that lit layers and data
layers that actually try to avoid
putting anybody in the center to play
God and that's the picture on the right
and in the picture on the right or the
on the screen here the picture on the
left is intended to show really a
network of independent actors right
connected to each other right talking to
each other sharing the transmitting
transactions to each other but
ultimately coming to a consistent state
in a consistent history of the events
that happened that's what these lines
here are coming off and up that's what
those boxes are going off to the left
clearly our art skills are not one of my
strong points but the point here is that
everybody on that network has the same
picture the same story of what happened
right and when you do that you end up
with with an interesting property no one
can go back in time and change an entry
in that ledger to mean something else
right and that isn't forced not just by
social convention this is enforced using
cryptography on each link from one to
the next where the previous link is
signed and it becomes part of the the
signature for the next one becomes a
signature for the next one and so if you
try to change something in the middle
the signatures don't check out anymore
right so in this way the history can be
verified simply by comparing the last
signature in that chain of transactions
that chain of blocks which is why it's
called a blockchain the interesting
question is well how does that network
come to an agreement on what is the next
entry in that chain right I when you're
talking about a very small network and a
very slow rate of transactions it's
pretty easy right somebody says you know
I've got a clicker somebody else says
I've got a glass of water and everybody
can hear what everyone is saying but
what if there's a lot of nodes on the
work and there's a lot of proposed
transactions and things get very buzzy
well this is why people care quite a bit
in blockchain technology about these
things called consensus mechanisms and
you might have heard of the term
Byzantine fault tolerance that you might
have heard about Paxos these are all
names for algorithms and approaches to
trying to resolve that problem of who
gets to put the next link in the chain
and this is not there's not one answer
to this there's not there's algorithms
that work better if you're talking about
you know thousands of nodes but only a
slow transactions per second others that
work better if you're talking about ten
nodes and thousands of transactions a
second so but you want a set of options
now proof of work like I mentioned in
Bitcoin is just one of those and proof
of work is essentially a lottery that
says one of these networks wins the
prize by trying to compute this special
kind of like answer to a question that
everyone can quickly verify and so they
know okay node number 56 did win that
and so whichever block they accept is
good all right but there are a lot of
other approaches to it and kind of
coming to that realization that there's
other approaches is one thing that let
me jump in to the blockchain technology
and realize you could build something
interesting what's also interesting
about this question of how does a
network come to an agreement about that
series of transactions is well who is in
the network right and very much like
it's a it's a it's very much like who is
in this room right now Lori your your
pretend you all are nodes on a
blockchain network right all of you are
individual kind of like you know
companies or servers or whatever kind of
metaphor you want to use and let's say
all of you kind of mutually distrust
each other just enough to want to have
your own copy of the ledger right well
when one person standing up on stage
it's obviously very easy when somebody
throws out a question from the room it's
obviously very easy but if we start
getting chatty we need some way to
resolve that and that's what that's what
consensus mechanisms are all about
proof-of-work is one way but there are
plenty of others and if we have a
bounded finite space like we have here
in this room where there's somebody at
the door kind of like making keeping
tabs on who can come in it's much easier
for us to have a consensus mechanism
based essentially on one-person one-vote
rather than try
this kind of lottery and that's really
the big difference between what you
would call permissioned Ledger's
permissions blockchains which is
everybody in this room kind of you know
it can be one person one vote versus
unpermitted Ledger's which is we're out
on the street we have thousands of
people walking by no one really knows
each other but we use you know kind of a
lottery style kind of system to be able
to figure it all out
so that's distributed ledgers the second
big picture is the second part of that
is what what the term has been used is
smart contracts and people kind of wince
when they say that because the term
smart anything tends to you know should
be replaced by hackable in my opinion
yes smart-home hackable home you know
smart car hackable car but but the point
of a smart contract is this you can
write a script that you push out to the
entirety of the network right and this
is a piece of software that'll sit there
and based on some trigger it could be a
certain time it could be when it sees a
certain event will then run everywhere
on the network and it'll it'll execute
it'll either check hey what's the has
the temperature in Sacramento been a
hundred degrees Fahrenheit for the for
during the growing season right then pay
out this insurance contract for a farmer
right or you know if these other three
steps in some business process have been
completed then automatically assume that
a fourth one can be done you know
checklist style right now this seems odd
why would you push this out to all the
nodes in the network well in doing that
you end up writing software that doesn't
live in just one place it lives on the
network and when it all runs the network
comes to a consensus a convergence on a
common answer and when that that
consensus happens it gets written to the
ledger so this is useful to avoid a
scenario withers in like say an
insurance agreement where there's
counterparty risk right you sign in an
agreement with a company to pay you you
know if your farm suffers from drought
defined as temperature in Sacramento but
they don't pay because it turns out
they're not State Farm they are some
two-bit kind of insurance fly-by-night
that disappeared well this is a way you
know
if if this script runs and it says okay
automatically now there was a drought
transfer $1,000 or $10,000 to the
farmers account then the farmer knows
that they can get paid even if the
company that was behind it what went out
of business or couldn't be contacted
couldn't fulfill their commitments and
so there's lots of different financial
products that can be modeled as smart
contracts there's lots of other business
processes that could be modeled as smart
contracts but it's a way to get us out
of the tyranny of the centralized server
when it comes to not just storing of
data but processing of logic and that's
that's really cool so those are the two
fundamental kind of premises now you
notice in this whole conversation I've
been able to describe it without it's
talking about you need Bitcoin here you
need aetherium there these are
interesting applications of those two
principles and in particular I'm
fascinated by the etherium community's
idea of using a currency not just to as
a way to send money around to different
people but also to drive as what they
call gas these smart contracts write
some really advanced work being done
they're really fascinating but there's
also a lot of complexity that tries to
come especially from dealing with big
public anonymous networks like the
unpermitted networks try to do and so a
lot of the examples of those point two
to here actually don't even require
running things on top of such a complex
underlying infrastructure so at at hyper
little octane stuff that we've done
we've kind of seen three main kind of
categories of different blockchain
deployments starting now but but it's
certainly edge cases outside of this one
of those is in financial services right
so almost anything that involves a
ledger and financial services is right
for this whether it's bank wires whether
it's and sending money between banks
whether it's collateral trades insurance
products know your customer and any
money and tea money laundering kinds of
checks that are done when people open an
account all those sorts of things
supply chains I'll show you an example
soon and surprisingly in healthcare
which I can talk more about examples in
the QA but what would make up a really
good
instead of use cases that you would
apply to something like this and I'm
sorry if this is small I'll try to read
it and back but this is cribbed from the
World Economic Forum's report on
blockchain beyond the hype and this is
kind of a series of five different
criteria that you'd want to look for to
ask whether a use case merits being done
as a blockchain or should simply be done
as a centralized service kind of like an
uber right so one of them would be a
shared repository of information used by
multiple parties multiple writers to
that that ledger you know who are kind
of more like peers to each other rather
than one in one kind of a at the center
where there's a minimal amount of trust
between the parties involved where right
now there's generally an intermediary or
a central gatekeeper that's being used
to try to enforce that trust and where
there's dependencies upon transactions
now I didn't really talk about this when
I gave the example of writing to a
blockchain you know I have a clicker in
my hand or here's a cup of water but
imagine I'm writing a transaction to a
ledger that says you know I'm giving
Jesse my clicker yeah take it that's
fine um don't click anything though and
and now there's this this red entry in
the ledger that says I've given a
clicker to Jesse now if I try to give
that same clicker to my wife Kate the
network would reject it
because the network says no you've
already given that to Jesse you don't
have the clicker anymore only Jesse can
hand that clicker off to anybody else
right so this series of dependencies in
the entries in the ledger is also a
critical part yeah thank you about how
these networks work so I so this is kind
of a rubric that you can use another
kind of way to divide up the space here
is to think about two different
dimensions to how these networks work
one of those is permission versus on
permissioned which I kind of mentioned
is kind of like is there a bouncer at
the door right
letting parties in kind of defining what
the rules are between folks with the
technical rules are but also the legal
agreements between parties and then how
visible is that network is it visible to
the public or is it visible only to that
private group and and there are there
are examples I'll give of public
permission networks in just a bit so the
one exam so they say diamonds or a
blockchain errs best friend and I use
this example
apologies if you've heard this but the
diamond industry has now two and a half
three years into using a blockchain to
track the flow of diamonds in in through
the industry this is an implementation
of a process that a treaty actually well
not a treaty it was a business agreement
between the participants in the diamond
industry called the Kimberley process
that built a tracking mechanism for AI
diamonds through the system to try to
keep blood diamonds out of the retail
network right and diamonds that had been
used in war zones and to pay for weapons
and that sort of thing and previously to
this this system had been implemented
using fax machines that were faxing
documents that were attached to each
diamond as the diamond would change
hands from one party to the next there
was a piece of paper with stamps on it
and that piece of paper would get faxed
essentially a copy of it sent to a
central repository in Antwerp through
which if you did care enough you could
take that piece of paper and say does
this piece of paper match the history of
that piece of paper operated by going to
that company that that nonprofit in
Antwerp aying I think it was a large
amount of money and getting that that
attestation but you really didn't know
looking at that statement you know what
those stamps meant what those signatures
meant etc so this was a pretty poor
system even though it had the right
intent when they moved to the blockchain
and this has now been in production for
the last year the idea here is that
everybody who deals with these diamonds
who pulls them out of the ground who
hands them to a distributor or to it to
transport it to set it into rings and
then finally to get it to the retail
network writes an entry to a shared
ledger between all of the different
participants and what's written to that
ledger is metadata of data about the
diamonds you know its shape its color
its size in some cases they can now put
a serial number directly onto the
diamond III that you can see by a
microscope but doesn't affect the color
or quality of it and there's other
techniques they're coming around to and
then whenever somebody receives that
they're right the second the other side
of that transaction I've received it it
does match these characteristics and
this looks good and so when you receive
this diamond
any point in this you can see in that
ledger the history of what's been
written and who wrote it and the
signatures left by the people who wrote
it and that history cannot be corrupted
it cannot be changed and remember how I
mentioned this concept of prevention of
double spend well this keeps a middle
person from being able to send the same
product to two different parties right
which would be a way for them to slip in
diamonds from the Congo or something
like that this has been in production
now for about a year it's already
processed millions of different diamonds
through the system and has blocked
millions of dollars worth of attempts at
fraud which they are very politically
kind and they say is missing paperwork
but I really you talk to the people
involved in the project and say yes
we've kept millions of dollars for the
attempts at putting fraudulent diamonds
into the market so that's pretty cool
the the fishing industry now is pursuing
a similar approach and in fish you have
a similar situation where you have fish
caught in regions that are acceptable
right where there's various treaties
that that correlate to different species
of fish where they allowed to be caught
so it's to protect fisheries and so is
to protect the long term fishing stock
so every legit fisherman has an interest
in participating in this system and
intrinsic interest as well as the
processors because it helps preserve the
long-term viability of their industry
and so I this is not an operation yet
but it's being built it's the same kind
of idea here's a load coming off a boat
here's a load that's being you know a
processed fish now that came from this
source here's now it going into the
market that sort of thing so that when
you go to Whole Foods and something says
sustainably caught you should be able to
have much higher confidence that there's
actually something of substance behind
that right and this matters not just to
the consumer at Whole Foods this matters
to countries now that are starting to
try to keep pirate fish stocks basically
from entering entering the country in
the first place right and without a
traceability system like this you don't
really get anything of value you can't
really like attest to the integrity of
that system now what's different about
this than diamonds is that it tries to
address a problem that Sheila Warren at
the World Economic Forum coined which I
love which is you know most technologies
have a garbage in garbage out kind of
problem well block chains have a car
garbage forever problem and there's
nothing magical about this system that
means that when you write something to
it that it's true right it could be
completely bogus well so in addition to
trying to write you know this boat came
in to port and it unloaded its catch
fish that were caught at this time in
this region well how do you really know
that's true so in addition to that
ordinary data
what's also written is sensor data from
buoys floating out in the water from
sensors on the nets there are these
tamper proof GPS sensing and weight
sensing sensors for nets that now I can
take that data and record it into a
blockchain as well as information from
sensors in the eye like during the
shipping process as well that measure
not only GPS but also temperature so
that you know hey this was safely
transported this didn't sit in a
container at a hundred degrees
Fahrenheit for a week right so all of
this is used as extra data written to
the same ledger as the tracing data so
that somebody can try to connect draw
the connection here and it might be
possible for one piece of you know for
one shipment a fraudulent fish to come
in or from one package wallets and
transit to be swapped out for another
but by collecting an out like a chain of
evidence of this you'd hope to catch the
the large violations that would happen
out there the systematic violations
because you could then apply modern
techniques of machine learning and data
science and such to what it should be a
much higher quality data set than
average there's not a lot of time left
so I won't go deeply into this but this
is another deployment of blockchain
technology in production today which is
a global trade finance network that has
been set up between HSBC Deutsche Bank
Santander and about 10 other banks to
manage the entire trade finance process
from a letter of credit all the way to
final receipt of goods and this is not
seen a high volume of traffic I think
they process seven or eight transactions
on this network in the last few weeks
that they've been live but the goal here
is to standardize and routinize a whole
lot of processes that are either you
know point-to-point or back performed by
overworked back office staffs by
Ledger's that go out of sync with each
other and require
a lot of manual kind of intervention to
try to correct and to hopefully get the
entire process of applying for trade for
for trade finance for export credits and
then processing it all the way through
and finally getting paid to be much more
optimized than it is before so this is a
pretty exciting product project and just
like with the others there are entities
that act as conveners of this network
but they don't centrally hold the data
in any way what the data is held is the
data is held on the ledger and shared
between the different parties there I
have a final big idea which I really
don't have the time for but I block
chain technology is also going to be
critical to I believe getting us out of
the mainframe style a centralized
Identity Management stuff that we have
going on in the internet now where
instead of you being defined as log into
Facebook log or log in with Facebook log
in with Twitter instead being able to
store your personal data as well as add
a stations about you claims made about
you things like your birth certificate
your diploma your healthcare records
your financial records being able to
exist as data you can hold close to you
and something that looks and feels like
a wallet but then it you keep track of
using a blockchain who that's shared
with when it was shared and being able
to withdraw consent for the sharing of
that data so how many of you here know
what the GD P R is okay for many of you
it's perhaps been a pain in the ass in
the last few months it certainly
probably meant a lot of emails and click
throughs and kind of a questionable is
this actually going to have an effect
well the intent behind GD P R is to give
you agency over your data and there are
people who've been working on the
tooling to support that kind of concept
the ability to not only share and keep
in mind who you shared it with but be
able to pull that back or even just keep
the company you shared it with from
sharing it on to somebody else so there
are a number of projects out there
including one at hyper let your called
hyper ledger in D which are building
infrastructure for tracking that sharing
of data in the consents and the
withdrawal of that consent and
ironically blockchains which are all
about sharing data amongst everybody in
the room right amongst everybody on the
network R is the the perfect way
actually to keep try to allow us to get
to a world we're actually minimizing the
amount of personal data that we have to
be that that
share or feel like we have to share so
if I take the long view of this stuff
and and and you know you could say ask
whether it's ten years or five years or
twenty it's really hard to tell I swear
it was there at Wired one point saying
yeah eventually everything's gonna be
online but you wouldn't do something
crazy like buy a car on the internet or
anything like that so my efforts at
long-term prognostication especially
witnessed by not buying Bitcoin really
don't necessarily take as gospel but
I'll just try to read these real quick
so consortium formation forming these
kinds of blockchain networks these
governing entities that Shepard each of
these Ledger's that'll become pretty
routine right now it's pretty ad-hoc and
bespoke and we don't really know how to
form these things there's a few of them
out there but but we're gonna get really
good at that I think and have a couple
of templates for how either existing
organizations that act as a kind of
consortium in the business world either
take that role on or a brand-new
consortium and new for-profit companies
step in to perform that role I do think
most multi-sided market places become
blockchain networks right that could
even mean something like ride-hailing
for example right it could mean
something like Ikey Bay right becomes a
decentralized kind of system using
blockchain technologies it's really hard
to get that decentralized to the point
of average end-users standing up a full
node themselves but I think we'll find
ways for entities that can act as the
agents of the users to form these these
these Ledger's I think most bureaucratic
processes whether it's like starting a
business or getting a birth certificate
or diploma or selling a house or a car
will become blockchain based because
it's it's it just makes more sense for
that that kind of data to be stored
collectively or communally or tracked
collectively rather than being stored up
and only defined by what's in say a
government database right like you know
your driver's license should be
something that you have physical
possession of in a digital way rather
than just an entry in a database in a
California government what computer
right or a cloud somewhere where that
ephemerality means it actually could
disappear at any point and so this is
about building a much more resilient I
think system when it comes to managing
that kind of thing and then finally I I
think I the
I'm in this is not just because you know
enterprises are cool and the Linux
Foundation is cool we have a serious
warrant truth right and it didn't start
in 2016 although we felt it really
sharply then and we still feel it
sharply but it shouldn't be as hard as
it is for us as communities at all sorts
of different scales to come to a common
ground truth about the world right to
agree on a set of facts to agree on what
happened on July 4th 1776 right and we
actually it used to be that if something
was an event was published in the
newspapers of the world
we had microfiche copies of those
newspapers we could go back and see you
know what happened maybe not July 4th
1776 but you could see what happened on
a certain date in 1923 and how that was
reported we you know the digital world
is still you know despite the best
efforts of folks at the Internet Archive
and elsewhere still to ephemeral to
necessarily trust really vital stuff
like this - and so there's a lot of
people believed by by super distribution
of a lot of this information by
essentially all of us acting as notaries
on everyone else's transactions right we
can get more much more quickly to a
common ground truth for things and maybe
that means technology reclaims its role
as a tool of liberation and justice but
who knows one of the things I want to
start with is you know there's a lot of
excitement we understand how blockchain
as a technology works and and you're
building new tools for it but let's talk
about the dependencies for some of these
use cases so let's let's look at the
sustainable seafood case and tell us
what are the pieces of that and do they
exist that are that are they out there
and deployed do we have you know IOT in
the seas that's validating that the
where these need to come from what are
what are what's that ecosystem if you
will of technology and how much of those
things are in place and how much is
almost there and how much are further
off can you give us a sum of the terms I
don't think it's a hardware problem like
I think there are devices now that are
available off-the-shelf to be able to do
the kinds of stuff I mentioned there's a
company called smart catch that makes
these sensor net sensors actually then
they even have video cameras
them so you can see the kind of fish
that you caught it's kind of crazy um
there are these sensors on buoys and at
ports and things like that to collect
that data that's real the blockchain
side of that picture is really simple
it's you know you stand up a network of
nodes and I mean this is what hyper
ledger is built this stuff is in
production now that ledger that chain is
not in production yet that's still being
developed Intel is one of the leads on
that but it they have gone to a number
of the different fish processors and and
some of the major fleet operators all of
whom are what they're trying to prevent
are the renegade fishermen who actually
offload their caches to legit fishermen
in weird waters right who then come back
into port and try to offload so I'd say
probably the biggest challenge will be
getting a critical mass of the
participants in any marketplace add
enough layers in the chain from
beginning to end to start working
together so that they basically shame
abide by it by working well shame the
rest into joining that network and maybe
that even means if you're not eventually
if you're not part of that network you
can't sell your fish not only the Whole
Foods but maybe not even to any any
supply any retailer in the United States
right so I think I think the it's the
but there's a bootstrapping problem with
a lot of these times and and so and just
to look at it a little bit more closely
so so it's so it's starting with the the
Fisher level to the merchant level is
the end point along the way there are
transportation legs that are there there
may be the port itself that needs to
have some infrastructure there and are
you seeing that or does it look like it
would be something online so it's like
the Good Housekeeping Seal that this is
like certified how does that I mean deep
to you and again this isn't obviously
your piece of it but I'm curious what
you're here because you're talking to I
mean in your role I think you are
encountering every piece of the folks
that are touching this stuff is it that
I would have a nap and I would be able
to see that this fish was and verified
myself or that the merchant is providing
that certainty at that level this is
still predominantly a
business-to-business technology right
and
should be the case that they'll be
eventually providers who act as a kind
of a portal for average consumers to be
able so that you know in theory Whole
Foods should be able to provide you some
sort of app that says where did my fish
come from that surface the data back to
that chain you still have to trust that
Whole Foods is telling you the truth
right so that you know but it could be
at some point that that ledger becomes
fully public and there's multiple ways
to get to it and verify it an example of
an application I'd really like to see
that looks more like that would be voter
registration rolls so a lot of people
talk about hey should we use the
blockchain to help manage elections and
I think it's a terrible idea to cast
votes using a blockchain because it's
really hard to simultaneously preserve
the integrity of the election and the
confidentiality of voters while being
able to audit it but you could use a
distributed ledger for the voter
registration side of it so that
everyone's looking at the same database
with regards to who's registered to vote
where and you could use it at the tail
end to which is what what's the summary
from each of the different locations
right each of the different polling
places in rolling rolling that up to
kind of a state level or a global kind
of national summary for how the vote
went right and in both those cases
having the public be able to see that
ledger each individual item write the
entire spreadsheet so to speak is
essential to building trust and
confidence in the process and so for
that I would fight for that to be very
public for something like diamonds you
know the participants in that market
have already gone through this complex
political balancing act of sharing just
enough information that they can audit
each other on where these diamonds came
from but not sharing things like the
prices they paid right and and other
metadata could be used by investors
perhaps to short stocks of companies
that they think might not be doing well
right so there's I'm a very Pro open
data kind of guy and transparency got a
guy but for a lot of good reasons the
business communities are only willing to
share data if they can't if it means
they can't get access to other things
right and in the case of the diamond
industry there is a mandate from the
policy makers to clean up their act when
it came to blood diamonds and that sort
of thing and that kind of pressure is
essential in a lot of these chains I
think these chains are a way to finally
extra things that economists consider
externalities in markets finally
reintegrated into the flow of goods and
and and Commerce you know whether that's
labor conditions or carbon credit you
know carbon load for example of the
different products flowing through or
you know other things correlating to the
sustainable development goals so that's
the idealist to me and that's kind of
why I'm involved in this and you've got
to have it create just enough economic
value business value for the businesses
to pick it up and use it because they
won't do that
just endogenously they need some
business problem that they can solve at
the same time so I know we're gonna get
a lot of great questions about
blockchain I want to take a kind of half
step back and talk about open source for
a second because and and and let's so on
that on that theme around ancestors so I
think that accounting methods start
around 7,000 years ago the to go all the
way back and then it's like twelve
hundred or something is when
double-entry I think started so then
closer to we said the web you know as
we're approaching how quickly was thirty
years ago it was twenty years ago I
believe that the open source initiative
came together so can you talk about
where open source was when you started
with when Apache was was starting not to
go too deep into it but just to give us
sort of a flavour because we're in a
very different moment now where it's not
as individual driven but you know you're
working with a lot of corporations on on
open source projects and that I I can't
imagine that 1996 Brian would have
imagined that that would be that would
be the case so I don't know what what
was your vision of where open source
would go so in the late 90s right so I
you know I went to Bourke
started as freshman at Berkeley in 91
and pretty much immediately found the
internet kind of fell into the same
rabbit hole that I think a lot of other
people fell into at the time or it's
like it's so much more engaging than
what I was learning in my classes right
but a lot of what I was learning was
about how internet architecture came
from people voluntarily working together
and not just saying hey this is how
things ought to be built but actually
building them and releasing that code
doing it out of an academic interest but
simultaneously you know it's not a very
good demo if it doesn't work so let's
make this production quality code at the
same time and the easiest way to do that
was to publish the source code in
addition to the software so that other
people could help you find your bugs I
fundamentally like really resonated with
the idea of put it out there let other
people Hammer it and tell you where
you're wrong and be able to recover from
that and evolve and that's where
internet email came from that's where
DNS came from that's where gopher an FTP
and IRC came from was people sharing
this code pretty freely and so when the
web came along what did Tim berners-lee
do he didn't start web Inc and and you
know release a proprietary web browser
and server he released the source code
to a next client and a Anna's and as a
web server that he wrote that also ran
out next right and then other people
started also writing open source we
didn't even have that word until 98 but
but free software you want to call it
that shareable code and so it almost
felt sacrilegious to start a proprietary
web company at the time although when
Netscape got started that was great but
but Apache felt like it was just
continuing it was the next iteration of
a pretty logical sequence that came
before and there wasn't a sense that it
was anti-corporate
I mean I did propose the name Apache
because I could wanted Association kind
of our on a romantic side with the
Apache Tribe or the last tribe of Native
Americans to surrender to the United
States and they paid a very heavy
penalty for that if anyone's been to the
Apache Tribe areas in Arizona they're
definitely or not as well office and the
other tribes out there and so I kind of
felt like you know as a joke we'd be the
last one standing before Microsoft took
over the web they owned the desktop at
the time so we thought that made sense
and and you had started what became
known as the Apache project correct and
and then how large was the group by the
time you
they were formalized that that nine of
us initially and then that became I mean
I don't even remember but it about 1990
by 97 it was clear that was on 60% of
the web sites at the time and which it
was one of the few pieces of software
you could actually measure how many
people were using it because you could
ask a web server at any IP address
what server are you running and so this
great place called net craft started
doing these monthly surveys and so you
get this gorgeous chart of the rise and
fall of you know well George because
Apache was at the time yeah sorry but uh
but it was very measurable and so when
that happened I think 97 was when we
first started fielding enquiries from
companies well a asking you know where
they send where they can send a purchase
order for Apache 2 and they're like no
it's it's free you know and they're like
well I don't know if our lawyers will
let us use this we're not coming after
you but then it took a couple people
warning us about things like patents you
know if a patent holder felt that we had
implemented something that covered one
of their claims as individuals we could
be sued for you know our livelihoods and
for our nest eggs and things like that
and and then it took a couple of our
companies including IBM kind of stepping
in and saying well there might be ways
to shield yourselves from that liability
by incorporating and a couple of other
people had said that as well and we also
felt then like none of us wanted to be
web server developers for the long term
or even full-time and yet we felt like
what we had come up with in terms of how
we worked which was very decentralized
very virtual it could be replicated all
right and so that was when so by 98 we
had launched the Apache Software
Foundation but that was with a lot of
help from a couple of corporations who
provided pro bono legal services IBM as
well as the company I co-founded organic
has been a lot on legal help to make
that happen and and branding and that
sort of thing right but we did we
created this this 501c3 nonprofit that
says served as a home and and now there
are many of these other organizations
that have spawned other software
foundations etc and all of them designed
to provide both the legal shield for the
developers as well as enough just enough
structure and and formation to be able
to allow the devs to contribute and
collaborate without taking on a
tremendous amount of either personal
liability or long term maintenance
unless they want it to be involved in
that and and at that time you guys are
all I assume your guys in your 20s you
know and then to cut to today so hyper
Ledger is a project of the Linux
Foundation character
to linux foundation for sure so the
Linux Foundation is a 501 C 6 so a
different kind of nonprofit but it's
more of an industry consortium funded by
membership dues of over a thousand
different companies now and within the
Linux Foundation there are a number of
funded projects so there's the Linux
kernel and a bunch of things that are
directly related to the operating system
but there's another project called the
cloud native compute foundation which is
the home for kubernetes and all this
other containerization work going on
there's a set of projects related to how
telcos use software and managing telco
routing infrastructure and then I
security related ones and hyper ledger
and and the idea then is companies pay
to be a member of the foundation they
also pay a little bit more to be a
member of these funded projects and then
they serve as a constituency of sorts
they have a board so I have 25 different
bosses I've got a governing board if a
couple of the the major companies
involved there as well as my own boss
Jim Semillon is the executive director
but we essentially have our own budget
then then we can decide how do we spend
that to act as air traffic control for
the software developer community we
don't write the code ourselves we don't
pay for that code to be written that
software development has to come from
the community that's a way of validating
that what's being built is actually
what's needed by the community not just
what I think personally should be built
right because I'm not going to have
nearly the good ideas that I think
others in the community will have about
what should be built in that that's done
often by large companies but also by
startups also by students in come cases
by by people out there who want to build
the next layer of plumbing for these
kinds of distributed applications all
right
we're gonna get to your questions going
here I think we got one right there yes
you mentioned that metadata can be
associated with transactions to be able
to identify fraudulent transactions
after the fact so to what extent can't
do these platforms support using that
metadata and automatic as opposed to
manual way to go way back in the ledger
and correct transactions well you get a
full copy of the ledger in this
simplistic model right is you get a
full copy of the ledger at every node
and you could certainly modify your own
copy of the ledger if you want but you
can't there's really no practical way
for you to hack into everybody system
and change everyone's old old entry
right nor is there even a way even if
everyone agreed if you changed an old
entry then the signatures don't match
right and so generally speaking you
don't do that you it you put some new
entry into that ledger that corrects for
what was written in the old one right
but that's just about changing entries
in the ledger obviously this presents an
issue when you run into regulations like
the right to be forgotten right or you
you wrote some other personally
identifiable information into the ledger
and want to purge it for some other
reason and so for that you actually
there's some types of data you don't
want to write to these Ledger's you want
to be able to delete them but you can
keep a pointer to that and a signature
of that so you can validate that that is
actually the data associated with that
entry in the ledger and then when it
comes to your metadata question I'm not
sure how to answer that right okay
thanks again
Stuart hi Fran is there an accumulation
problem as soon as you said garbage in
garbage forever I thought well is it a
situation of infinite data in garbage
forever how does the system collect its
garbage in the sense right so I just
bought a four terabyte hard drive
portable hard drive for a hundred and
fifty dollars right and and something on
the scale of the visa Network is twenty
thousand transactions per second which
would generate a couple of gigabytes a
day if you boiled it down to just the
account numbers and that the quantity
right turns out no one should think of
blockchain technology as a big data tool
you really want to optimize it for
numbers for it for capacity right which
means actually writing as little data to
it as you can as you can get away with
you want to be very concise and
describing it because it's what you want
everybody to have copied everywhere so I
think that is one thing that serves as a
natural constraint but otherwise when it
comes to the history of the ledger
they'll be approaches to dealing with
that amount of data you could simply say
okay
the world state as it's called this the
state of the ledger as of you know at
the end of every year is basically you
know it's it's reset you know you can
take that old series of entries archive
them somewhere people can keep copies of
that archive somewhere and you say okay
we're starting with a new Genesis block
as they call it where everybody's
balance is or everybody's assets are
distributed this way and then move
forward from there what you and you may
not even decide hey we can throw all
this away because it happened 20 years
ago and we don't care or it's beyond the
statute of limitations for something
right or something like that
but generally speaking I think in many
of these cases the storage isn't gonna
be a problem I think we know now know
how to store an arbitrary amount of data
at every node for a pretty affordable
amount of money I think the bigger
question will be transactions per second
and throughput and that'll be the bigger
limiter because getting an entire room
of nodes to agree on what the next entry
in the ledger is going to be is still
the rate limiting step and I you know
we're we considered lucky when we get to
five thousand transactions per second on
a given node so I think I think those
will be the the constraints that
introduced themselves to and along those
lines
is there any bomber blazer anything akin
to like a DDoS attack that I mean is
that are there and and related to that
are there learnings that are getting
shared as as problems and so forth come
up is how how is how are the what's how
are those getting shared across
community of technology so this is
another place where there's a big
difference between the permissions and
on permission networks write in a
permission network again like people in
this room if all of you started yelling
out questions at the same time you know
he he'd call an end to the event pretty
quickly right like or or some other
governance mechanism would kick in and
right that's what happens after we turn
off the mic everybody go we want that
but in a room without a bouncer right in
a none permission network you do need
other tools to be able to prevent
against bad actors right and and so this
is really the field of crypto economics
as it's been kind of called right it's
one very arguably plausible reason why
you might actually want to have
transaction fees at the heart of
some of your larger networks so that if
somebody did want to span it they have
to spend a lot of money
to spam it alright I and and yeah I
think the larger the network gets the
more likely it is to have to require
those kinds of mechanisms at small
scales of 10 to 100 nodes you might
simply have a convention that says right
you're allowed to write at a certain
rate or you're allowed to fill so much
capacity and if you go above that on a
regular basis or attempt to attack the
network you're booted out the network
the metaphor I've been using for the the
organization that would act as a
governing entity has been a referee on a
football field right which not only gets
across yeah there's a sort of you know
law enforcement kind of role but if they
end up doing a bad job or abusing their
position if they charge players a
hundred dollars to come onto the field
right they will get fired and so in the
design of these blockchain networks
it hasn't really come up yet but I think
as they mature a big question will be
how do you fire the ref how do you fork
when the governing entity gets too much
power essentially and that's going to be
another interesting evolution of these
networks Brian you you talked about
consortium formation and the importance
of consortium formation and it feels
like to a degree the prediction you made
is already coming to fruition that
consortiums are becoming easier to build
and we're having more and more people
solidifying around projects but it feels
like right now they are to some degree
empty consortium that there they've come
together they have a notion but there
aren't that many transactions we're
really not really in the production
phase and if you were a cynic and
certainly I'm not but you might say that
people were doing this to to issue press
releases and so I guess what I would ask
is when the technology alone is
insufficient to drive us to production
what are the other critical factors that
need to be in place for us to get over
that hump and actually like start
putting all the fish on the blockchain
and all the diamonds on the blockchain
and really be you know operating at the
level that the internet does today how
do we how do we get blockchain from this
test stage to the production stage well
in the early days of the internet I mean
of the web it was rife with websites
launched as press release
where many of the first websites were
literally and I know because this was
what organic did for a lot of time
take a paper brochure scan it in turn it
into HTML and put it up right where
interactivity and being web native was
kind of took a while that come along
right there is a lot of not only hype
but optimism and like build it and
they'll come kind of Field of Dreams
kind of stuff that happened then and I
think that's got to be a recurring
pattern in technology movements right I
don't know that people are being
irrational in thinking that it's someday
this will pay off it's really a question
of bootstrapping right and I don't think
you bootstrap with 40% of a market place
jumping on board you know instantly
right I think you need the first 10
transactions and then the first hundred
transactions right I to to bear out
before it'll actually happen I think
Sergey Brin had said he doesn't want to
be the first space tourist but he'll be
the thousandth space tourists because
the first 999 will shake out the bugs in
the system right I kind of agree with
that and I think likewise no one wants
to be the first I mean it's like who is
the first fax machine right kind of joke
and so so I think that bootstrapping
problem will hit and that's why some
industries will pick it up sooner like
trade finance and and even healthcare
which is not normally an early adopter
of these technologies but where there's
some easy wins in that but even within a
given sector like healthcare records may
take forever to get there right
whereas certifications of doctors and
and where they're allowed to practice is
a much easier thing to solve with this
so I don't know I think I think across
different sectors we'll see simply see
different rates of pick up and it's
gonna take early wins and and not based
on ROI but based on we did this and we
can see a straight line to eventually a
paying off I'm just I'm stuck with the
lonely guy with the first fax machine
calling their friends to see if they've
gotten one yet
I sold faxes in college it was a lot of
fun there two aspects that you touched
on a little bit that I think are kind of
ripe for disruption and for lack of a
better term one it's democracy in one's
education so in both of these cases
we have you know if you're in the 49%
you're screwed basically in democracy if
you have one person one vote and can
these technologies address that and
similarly in education if you know if
you went to Stanford or Harvard
everybody just looks at that one word
and you're done everybody else has to
prove what they've done to prove you
know Khan Academy and every other step
they've ever taken so do you see and
those you know kind of key aspects of
our identity do you see blockchain
changing how we relate to each other I
can't promise that it'll make the world
more fair and I nor can I promise
obviously it makes the world more
willing to look at those facts and make
judgments based on them right we have
that's that's a big problem right I do
hope they can make the world more
auditable and and what by that I mean
like that the business processes that
end up getting modeled into using
blockchain technology and having a
physics to them that prevent wherever
they can
fraudulent transactions from being
recorded in the first place because I
think look the unjustice that I feel it
exists in society most strongly are
people who think the laws don't apply to
them right who cut corners who don't
yeah you who you know it just feels like
that there's there's the way that the
world should work and then there's a lot
of wormholes through that that people
have found ways to to take and not have
to pay a penalty for right and I don't
necessarily right but it yeah but uh but
if if we can use this tech to make the
world more more auditable more but just
by the way that it works right to try to
keep bad actors from being able to to do
things in the first place right or if
they exist for a pattern to be
established and for them to be much more
incentive to stop the behaviors that
today they can get away with then that
feels pretty good to me now we still
have to have a conversation on how we
come up with those rules in the first
place right
that's still hard hard work and this
totally could go in a black mirror
dystopian kind of direction to at least
we should be conscious about that
whereas I feel like in the early days of
the web we felt that greater
interconnectivity wasn't unalloyed good
and I maybe we're more mature about that
now I don't know but I kind of hope so
so we have to deal with let's go back to
mark
let's go back to the big the big energy
consumption problem around Bitcoin and
around proof-of-work specifically that's
that's not an ideal design from where we
stand from a climate standpoint now so
how do you think about that to use are
there things that you see that are out
there now whether they are theoretical
or starting to happen are there things
that with the work that you're doing
specifically that you are looking at any
of these things or do you think it's
yeah a little ways off before we can
improve on that situation it is right
now the best technology for taking a
network of complete unknowns who have no
relationship to each other ignore any
kind of legal relationship with each
other or commitment to each other to be
able to build a distributed application
I I have to admit that right like like
Bitcoin and ethereum have grown to a
certain scale and it's not clear like
what problem they're solving but it is
clear that they've been able to build
something that has a lot of users and a
lot of wealth being transferred across
the network right and just to give it
its due credit and and there hasn't been
an alternative consensus mechanism yet
that has stood up to the test of
handling those kinds of loads there are
a lot of determined people in the
etherium community hoping to get to
something different called proof of
stake where basically instead of one CPU
cycle one vote you have one token one
vote so which kind of you could describe
as those who have money get to vote on
who gets more money you know which also
doesn't feel great you know it might
introduce its own negative externalities
but it's at least an alternative that
doesn't consume that amount of power and
there are probably some ways to keep
those that balance of that concerns
about over concentration of wealth and
power in that network to a to a minimum
but it's still unsolved and I think even
if aetherium does make that leap from
one consensus mechanism another I don't
think Bitcoin will because too much of
the Bitcoin mining community is firmly
attached to proof of work and would
consider you know a waste of the capital
investment that they've made to transfer
sorry I suspect it'll have problems if
it doesn't if it doesn't find a way to
switch over it's a point
all right do we have one more in the
audience there we go yes okay am I on
yeah okay good so Brian I'm a great fan
of open source and therefore a great fan
of Linux and and the idea of hyper
ledger and I'm wondering if I look at
the various use cases of hyper ledger
and the various partners have been
brought on yeah I see a lot of the IBM's
of the world and I'm wondering how you
navigate that hopefully you're only
seeing one IBM on that list cuz they
only have paid their dues once but but
you're right there's also Oracle and s
AP and kind of this old guard there's
also a lot of startups there's there's
like an Airbus and a Daimler there and
then there's Chinese startups with
unpronounceable names that are doing
interesting things and energy and
healthcare the Beijing genomics
Institute BGI which is if there's any
one place that is most likely to be
Jurassic Park I went and visited this
place outside Shenzhen where they have
like a woolly mammoth statue out front
because they're part of that project
right so it's a pretty broad based kind
of thing affecting a lot of industries
and to IBM's credit they've said this is
right next to AI there are two big Hail
Mary passes for IBM's future they put on
the order of 40 FTEs to writing software
all day and as soon as they write it it
gets checked into a public repository
and they are they I think they've said
400 or so they find 400 deals with
customers to do pilots and and
production systems and and that sort of
thing so I do credit for them they've
got in advance over a lot of the other
companies in this space but we now have
a vendor directory with 60 different
companies in it who have building
products and services on top of the
different technologies built at hyper
ledger so I'm feel pretty good that it's
not gonna be something that where the
wealth accrues to just one player but it
very much is a duoc receipt like in any
open source community it's really the
companies that get and have their
developers get involved and build that
underlying infrastructure that are best
positioned to then reap the benefits of
building things on top of that
all right and there's a last sort of
thought so this is called we call this
the foundation of trust and the
blockchain future zooming forward twenty
years thirty years give the same Tim
berners-lee number to this perfect place
in technology we're at right now thirty
years from now
don't worry about how it's done but the
goal of trust and certainty in business
contracts and so forth is done
blockchain is executed perfectly just as
always as technology tends to be how can
use can you imagine that world for a
second for us and and and tell us what
what that changes as far as does it
change the way our business
relationships work are is they're kind
of more cash because we have to do less
sort of auditing and five of these are
self what's yeah how do you how do you
sort of see or they're friction new
frictions that are removed from certain
types of relationships give us a couple
thoughts about that just knowing that
you'll probably be wrong as you said
before but this is not investment advice
because no what do I
it's hardly to separate what I think is
likely and what I hope is likely because
I tend to just focus more on what I
would we do scenarios here so you can do
two you could do two scenarios at all
right well right what I hope it happens
is that it helps us as a society figure
out how to create rules for how we live
and operate that don't become a joke as
soon as they're committed to paper right
like the idea now of industry
self-regulation is a joke as soon as
like MIDI says it right but an industry
that gets together and builds a
blockchain to trace the flow of diamonds
you're still gonna need auditors you
still need inspections you still need
some degree of correction for bad actors
but at least the tracing of the data is
there at least the ground truth can be
established in a way that it can't
without it and I hope that leads to
again more auditable kinds of kinds of
Susu something they're rejecting thirty
years out does it mean we're less
cynical about finding ways to balance
economic growth with economic justice I
mean with like issues around economic
justice or around access to to you know
what's considered like like a healthy
lifestyle or
better livelihoods you know things like
the sustainable development goals you
know if we can find ways to weave each
of those goals each of these things are
a metric right and if we can and we're
only gonna get to a metric if we do one
of two things survey which has a huge
amount of error or self-report you know
like guess what you know North Korea's
poverty rate will be right or find ways
to wire the systems of the world to
trace these externalities so that we get
an exact report of how many girls are
educated in Pakistan or what is the
carbon load of the Nike shoes that we're
wearing right like there's there's two
ways you could go about it and if we
instrument this into the systems of the
world I think we'll do better so because
the way today it works is that
regulation gets somebody whether it's
Facebook or an energy company regulation
is a looming thing and they go no it's
cool we're gonna self-regulate we'll
take care of it and then it becomes a
much you know a much lower it's a joke
because there's yeah but but maybe with
this kind of thing there'd be a way for
them actually to work together on
something that's that's a more and have
an appropriate role for auditors and for
regulators you know this isn't about
doing away with government in my opinion
because they're women still represents
the collective interests of the citizens
right in a way that businesses don't but
it might make it a much more a much
fairer way for regulators to be involved
or much less overhead taxing kind of way
for parties you know regulators to be
able to monitor what goes on in markets
and look for bad actors and correct
alright so that's all the time we have
for in stage Brian's gonna stick around
I know you have tons more questions
please stick around and ask Brian and
keep the conversation going amongst
yourselves as well let's have one big
round of applause for Brian
[Applause]
and and as is our tradition this is a
long now challenge coin to thank you for
doing it and remind you to seize the
millennium so thanks again and like I
said please stick around and one more
big round of applause for you thanks for
sticking around for a little bit later
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]